[Rires]
à
voici les premières notes du carnaval
2010 9,7 gros pot total participent au
concours la voix vide et ils ont 100
minutes pour convaincre le jury le
public cinq minutes de création alors
certains ont choisi de faire un mix des
chansons de carnaval
d'autres ont travaillé leur texte ils
sont en lien avec l'actualité en
chansons il parle d'internet et ses
dégâts des problèmes dans les ménages ou
encore de la jeunesse des thèmes et
d'échographie bien différente pour
chacune des formations
alors quand on leur parle de concurrence
nous un peu plus au mieux qu'à ça la
concurrence oui beaucoup
il faut qu'on gagne on avait le
troisième puis au jeu 7 francs pour le
premier dont le public
ambiance plutôt calme on observe dans
les moindres détails avant de faire son
choix
turbulences
ouais on n'a pas ce qu'on fait on est
arrivé on étend et franchement ça marque
et franchement ça les costumes comment
il
j'ai bien aimé
c'est bien parti de bon niveau ouais
mais bon c'est comme la ola où elle
avait rassuré après deux heures de show
pour le jury sénou moment de faire les
comptes n'est pas terminé on n'entend
pas de collecter n'est pas fini suspense
réussi à vous mettre tous d'accord ni gt
gt facile choix presque fait seulement
le jury nous confie que cette édition
est témoin shot que les années
précédentes
il manque encore un gros gâteau donne un
petit quelque chose pour nous hisser
encore à d'autres sommets mais je ne
désespère pas que ça vienne aller fin du
suspense
[Applaudissements]
où ils les bandes des trois îles et
remporte le concours lavaud à vide et
2019 avec son titre 3g il ouvrira les
défilés du carnaval avec cette musique
et histoire que tout le monde la
fredonne en choeur les chansons
devraient être diffusés sur toutes les
ondes de la marque puma
[Musique]